Speaker 1: We are increasingly in a COVID
hellscape in the United States as the Macron
variant or the omni cron as some refer to it,
including the president, is spreading wildly. It
is now believed that there are over a million real
cases a day real infections a day in the United
States, as the official numbers are swirling in
the 300000 to 400000 range. Most at home tests
when people test positive aren't figured into
that. People who never get tested because they
just have mild cold symptoms or can't access it
has never figure into that. There's probably a
million cases a day in the U.S. already. Florida
is a leading place that is experiencing these
incredible numbers. And Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis is completely missing. Article
from The Hill Where is Ron DeSantis now? Florida
mayor slams governor amid new surge. Orange County
Mayor Jerry Demings, that is. The husband of
Congresswoman Val Demings, by the way, Jerry
Demings, criticized Ron DeSantis, his handling
of Florida's COVID surge. Demings instated a
mask mandate for county employees. Some testing
sites have wait times as long as five hours.
We have not received any assistance from the
state of Florida at our testing sites. Where is
the Santas? Listen, this has been largely absent.
Our residents are all Florida residents should be
outraged and they should ask the question Where
is our state? Where is our governor? Where is
Ron DeSantis now? DeSantis has not held a
COVID briefing since December 17th, nearly
two weeks ago. He appeared alongside the Florida
surgeon general to promote monoclonal antibodies
developed by AstraZeneca. A spokesperson for
the Florida Department of Health told the
Orlando Sentinel Wednesday Florida's containment
efforts have shifted from an earlier state wide
undertaking to a number of locally led endeavors,
basically saying We're not really involved anymore
and we are really seeing a lot of passing the buck
here. I already have been critical of Joe Biden.
After running on, I will fix COVID, saying there's
no federal solution for COVID. It's it's got to be
run by the state in the state of Florida, the
governor's office is now saying there is no
state solution here. It's got to be run at the
municipality level. There's a lot of different
things going on and there is plenty of blame
to go around and also the reality that this is
happening everywhere. I'm not looking to uniquely
place blame on individuals for something that
is a global phenomenon. Akron is so contagious.
Increasingly, people saying, I don't do anything.
I went to the grocery store 15 minutes and wore
mask and I ended up with the disease. It is so
contagious that to some degree, no one's going
to really contain it. But we've got to be able
to do testing. We've got all these things that
are going wrong. And Jerry Demings is saying,
Where is this and this? He's just completely
missing. Let's take a look at a clip of that.
Speaker 3: Arizonans, all Florida residents should
be outraged and they should ask the question Now,
where's our state? Where's our governor?
Where is Ron DeSantis now? When was
the last time you saw the governor do
a press briefing regarding COVID 19?
Speaker 4: When was the last time Florida man
held a press conference on COVID? Now, according
to the Orlando Sentinel, it was on December 17th,
which is almost two weeks ago. And in those two
weeks, the state of Florida has seen an increase
in COVID cases of more than 1000 percent.
In fact, the state just reported a record
breaking number of new cases today, the most
since the pandemic began. Now, of course, this
comes after a Florida man implemented oppressive
restrictions, severe restrictions on private
businesses back in November, preventing them
from being able to require vaccinations and also
prohibiting mask requirements in schools.
Speaker 1: So the numbers in Florida are
truly incredible. If you're looking on your
screen if rather than just listening today,
this is not a glitch. This very thin line for
yesterday, which says 46, nearly 47000 cases in
Florida in a single day. That is correct. Now,
of course, of course, putting politics aside,
the hope is that the continued
lower hospitalization rate of Macron
will mean that not nearly as many cases are
going to turn into deaths, unfortunately.
If you look at Florida's death numbers, it looks
like there are almost literally no deaths taking
place. We know that's not true. And that's because
of how Florida reports deaths. They report them on
a major delay. So it always looks like there has
been almost no deaths recently. So we don't really
know in Florida to what degree cases are
turning into deaths because the reporting
is number one delayed a number two, potentially
incomplete. But Ron DeSantis continues to just
be missing in action as Florida nearly 50000.
Florida has dramatically more cases a day now
than many countries many, many countries around
the world. Florida has a lot of people as well,
of course, but their rate is off the
charts, and that's only official cases
doesn't include most at home tests unless you
call an authority health authority and report it
and doesn't include everybody who doesn't even
get tested. So the next six weeks are going
to be brutal in terms of case numbers and six
weeks from now, we will either come out of this
with an insane amount of death. Hopefully,
hopefully we will come out of it without
a ton of death due to milder disease. That's
still the hope and the belief as of right now
and with dramatically reducing case numbers
as we are already seeing in South Africa,
that those are the possibilities. Let me know
on Twitter at Packman, which you expect to see.
It is almost the end of 2021. Saturday, January
one, is it Saturday? Is Saturday, January 1st.
It is Saturday, January one. We are kicking off
the midterm year with a huge one day membership
discount special. I would love for you to
participate. You can get notified of this special
simply by being on my mailing
list, which you can sign up for
at David Pakman dot com. The David Pakman Show
is primarily funded by viewers and listeners
like you, people who listen to the podcast
or watch us on free speech TV or on any of
our television affiliates, listen on the
radio. Watch clips on YouTube. And you can
sign up for our membership program at join Packman
dot com. Cheap, Quick, Easy. You get an extra show
every day just for you, as well as a commercial
free audio and video stream of the show. And you
can get a discount off of a membership with the
coupon code better. 21. You can also wait for the
January one discount, which is going to be big,
very, very big. Lawyers, accountants, regulators,
they're very concerned about how big this discount
is going to be. We're going to do it. I will risk
jail time to give you a discount. Get on my
mailing list at David Pakman dot com. You'll
be notified January 1st of how to avail
yourself of this membership special